quand une crise survient ils prennent
les devants de l'événement mission
raisonner les forcenés convaincre les
malfaiteurs ce sont les négociateurs
à tirer
quand on est formés à la négociation
rêve de travailler de négocier sur
détournement avion car je vais proposer
le marché s'ils refusent
ils s'en sortent on veut négocier de
longues heures il ya un moment où
effectivement
on négociera plus quand les mots ont
échoué l'intervention armée se déclenche
entre alors en scène les professionnels
de la sau
négociateurs et spécialiste de l'action
de force sont tous issus des unités
spécialisées de la gendarmerie ou de la
police
aujourd'hui ils délaissent l'uniforme
pour le costume croisé du secteur privé
dans un monde globalisé où tous les
risques doivent être maîtrisées
en a4 extorsion en cours on a un coût
[Musique]
leur histoire commence à munich
septembre 1972 jeux olympiques d'été des
terroristes palestiniens s'introduisent
dans le pavillon israélien
deux athlètes sont abattues 9 tombe
entre les mains du commando baptisé
septembre noir les pourparlers
s'engagent il est conclu que les
activistes et leurs otages seront
transportés en egypte en fait ce n'est
pas une négociation mais un piège visant
à donner l'assaut
philippe madelin est un journaliste
écrivain durant toute sa carrière
professionnelle il s'est spécialisé sur
les questions de police de justice et de
sécurité comme tous les grands reporters
de son époque il a couvert munich le
fait divers planétaire
ont nommé ne sais pas vraiment on
essayait d'obtenir que les tories se
découvrent pour pouvoir les tirer au
fusil à lunette voilà en plus ils
étaient 8 il n'y avait que cinq tireurs
d'élite les tireurs d'élite en question
n'étaient pas des vrais tueurs d'élite
mais simplement des champions de tir ce
qui est pas tout à fait pareil ils
étaient équipés d'armes sans lunettes et
ses autres produits tel foutoir complet
n'irai pas de préparation sur cette
affaire-là et c'était surtout cette idée
de d'abattre le commando plutôt que
d'obtenir
progressivement elle ne la souplesse pan
de leur position pour
les aider à se rendre ou éventuellement
évacués et ont relâché leurs prisonniers
l'aso tourne au fiasco tous les otages
périssent exécuté dans cet hélicoptère
c'est un drame qui signe dans la douleur
l'acte de naissance des unités d'élite
occidental
tout est à revoir la façon de négocier
et la manière d'intervenir
deux mois plus tard le premier groupe
d'intervention de la police nationale le
gipn est fondée à marseille
[Musique]
marseille les eaux du vieux port ont
toujours exhaler l'odeur de la poudre
sel des calibres et du trafic d'héroïne
dans les années 70 et 80 c'était aussi
le terrain de chasse d'un négociateur
précurseur georges nguyên van loc et le
patron historique du groupe
d'intervention de la police nationale de
marseille vietnamien d'origine on
l'appelle le chinois et il est réputé
pour son franc parler comme ce jour où
deux toxicomanes armés retiennent qu'une
personne âgée
comme toujours ils entament le dialogue
est profond son marché
je suis le commissaire n'djeng guyane
bolloc'h je leur ai mis les points sur
les i si vous touchez à la vieille dame
je rentre gens pensent la porte et je
vous à bas tous les dons qu'il se sent
quelque peu
affolée et ils m'ont supplié de leurs
avoirs de doses de drogue je les ai
glissé sous la porte je dis maintenant
vous avez une dose de drogue je me donne
trois minutes pour sortir
[Musique]
le panier vieux quartier populaire situé
au coeur de la cité phocéenne pour le
chinois c'est là que tout a commencé
vannes oc qui a grandi ici il a appris à
parler aux bandits ses camarades de jeu
ses voisins de palier ont écrit la
légende du gangstérisme méridionale dans
le quartier c'est un peu comme en corse
il y avait en bas il y avait
dix ans le belge il y avait
les guérini encore le petit village
autour d'une table vous avez le voyou le
général magistrats le procureur c'était
la pax du village
aujourd'hui les bars de l'enfance du
chinois sont devenus des lieux culturels
à la mode
avant j'étais celle qui est mon ami
pierrot qu il avait l empire vous avez
abandonné il voulait des frigidaires
l'ailier alors écoutons mondiaux restent
eux disent il faut être comme pour mieux
les trucs qui a pris plus encombrant
qu'elle mérite
mais après il m'a dit jo je te promets
au milieu
des gazinières
un dégringolait au camp ça va ça va
le terrain ne s'apprend que dans la rue
et au contact des gens qu'on affronte
cette eau
et c'est pas derrière mon bureau comme
aura des affaires
il faut toujours connaître son
adversaire et pour connaître r il faut
le côtoyer il faut dix ans savoir qui en
est à faire
[Musique]
j'apporte
aux beaux jours du commissaire en cas de
prise d'otages van loock est en première
ligne il négocie mais derrière ces
hommes se tiennent prêts à intervenir la
force de frappe de l'inité donnent leur
véritable poids aux maux du chinois josé
d'arrigo est un chroniqueur judiciaire
qui a couvert toute sa carrière elle
décide alors de un mano à mano avec le
malfaiteur qui retranché avec un otage
ou plusieurs otages va lui parler il va
lui parler à la régulière parce que
benoît qui était un policier et un homme
régulier toujours il va dire petit ou
bien tu me donnes ton arbre et tout va
bien se passer tu feras quelques mois de
prison peut-être davantage mais tu
restera en vie
si tu veux jouer avec moi je te le dis
maintenant tu vas perdre et si tu perds
tu vas mourir
et une bonne note
tenez toujours parole
[Musique]
van loock entend le langage de ceux qui
vivent à la marge ce jour là il tente de
raisonner un homme armé par son verbe
toujours très marseillais vous êtes un
ouvrier moi je suis fils d'ouvrier alors
je vous respecte mes jeunes dans ce que
vous me respecte et je veux que vous
respectiez méga
mais non mais maintenant je vais vous
dire petit je te voir comme ça
maintenant je vais te tutoyer parce que
j'ai de l'affection pour toi tu es jeune
tu pourrais être mon fils mais tu sais
pourquoi les truies en de marseille de
lire mon respecte mais parce que je suis
je me garderais régulier tu comprends
mais pourquoi veux-tu te mettre le
pétard sur la tête
mais non petit ne me dis pas ça tu à 32
ans la vie hébert encore qu'est ce que
tu qu'est-ce que tu déconnes moi je
donnerai des millions pour avoir 32 ans
mais oui petit je suis persuadé qu'on va
s'entendre parce que nous sortons nous
tous les deux nous sortons du même
creuser
tulle est votre chargeur et tu mets ton
calibre devant la porte et puis moi je
viens on a discuté tous les deux
alors que je suis facilement
reconnaissable parce que j'ai la gueule
de l'asiatique je suis peut-être pas
beau mais c'est comme ça
j'étais parole tapant dans leurs mains
vous n'avez pas la détente facile devant
notre pas du tout si on se souvient
qu'il était ils étaient menacés en
permanence par des voyous comme mesrine
ou comme d'autres grands voyous à
l'époque comme gaëtan zampa etc et le
belge par la suite ce garçon là au
contraire je vous le dis a été très
calme il n'a fait usage de son arme que
dans les cas les plus extrêmes c'est lui
qui a compris que s'ils voulaient sortir
un otage des mauvaises situations
fallait discuter alors comme lui la tb
extrêmement encouragés au plan personnel
il a commencé à comprendre que pour
discuter il faut obtenir l'ouverture du
dialogue avec le preneur d'otages essaie
de tout ce dialogue dans toute cette
discussion qu'il a réussi un certain
nombre d'affaires d'opération et en
réétudiant après les conditions de
réussite d'ailleurs souvent
c'est en réétudiant qu'il a on a réussi
à théoriser à développer manière d'être
totalement différente de ce qui était
vrai à l'opposé d'un van loock un flic
qui marche à l'instinct un gendarme
commandants historiques du groupe
d'intervention de la gendarmerie
nationale
le gign dans les années 70 christian
prouteau va entreprendre les bauges
d'une théorie de la négociation il est à
la tête d'un groupe militaire les
opérations ils sont codifiés millimétré
réglée comme une montre suisse
allaitantes eaton elle reprend
le symbole du gène il reste du gène en
simplifier et à leurs appels sur le côté
en 1973 la date de création et 2003 la
date et 30 ans
de toujours quand on fait des opérations
l'a vu brisé sur la montre pour le top
actions
parce qu en intervention ce qui se
voudrait pas pesé mais le temps compte
beaucoup et quand vous négociez ça peut
durer des heures puisque vous évoquez la
négociation que ça vous tenait à coeur
mais quand vous intervenez ça dure des
minutes qui vous paraissent des heures
et cette espèce de l'élasticité du temps
que d'ailleurs les cameramans ont très
bien très bien imagé en faisant des
ralentis est une réalité professionnelle
c'est à dire que pendant une seconde il
se passe quelque chose
[Musique]
la vocation internationale du gign
s'affirme dès sa création
l'unité effectué ses premières armes à
djibouti
1976 c'est la guerre froide
officieusement soutenu par les
soviétiques un obscur commando du front
de libération des côtes somalie
interceptent un bus de ramassage
scolaire rempli d'enfants d'expatriés
français leurs exigences le retrait des
forces françaises de djibouti
inacceptable pour la france la
négociation qui s'engage n'a qu'un but
faciliter l'intervention nous était
indispensable de créer appelons ça une
diversion cette diversion c'était
d'obtenir et ça ça a été le rôle de
négociateur d'obtenir que il fasse
manger les enfants ce qui fait qu'à
partir du moment où ils ont fait manger
les enfants les enfants qui étaient déjà
fatigués se sont plus ou moins assoupi
et ont amélioré bien que la qualité du
tir et était indispensable pour aller
toucher ont amélioré les conditions de
l'intervention
deux enfants seront tués durant l'assaut
mais dans l'enfer du désert c'est un
succès qui fait office de baptême du feu
pour le gign au fil des prises d'otages
l'unité va perfectionner ses méthodes la
négociation devient un outil de gestion
de crise amener les gens soient à se
rendre la reddition est temps pour nous
là le geste le plus beau soit à nous
donner les moyens de savoir ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur de la crise de
d'arriver à mener le personnage où les
personnages qui sont qui lui sont
opposées vers une situation qui nous
arrange situation géographique ou
situation psychologique
de pouvoir juger également de sa
détermination de voir si effectivement
il est rare jusqu'au bout ou pas de voir
dans la manière dont il nous répond s'il
ya une chance ou non d'aboutir à une
arrestation sans suite l utilisation d
armes en
[Musique]
entraînement du gign sur détournement
d'avion un exercice obligé car depuis
plus d'un quart de siècle
la prise d'otages dans les avions est
devenu l' arme ultime dans l'arsenal des
extrémistes de tous bords la crise de
marignane en décembre 1994 fait figure
de référence dans l'histoire
opérationnel de l'unité les négociateurs
en ont tiré de nombreux enseignements
sur la psychologie de l'otage
quand l'airbus d'air france se pose sur
le tarmac de marseille provence la
veille de noël les trois pirates de
l'air affiliés au groupe islamique armé
ont déjà exécuté trois passagers dont un
français
[Musique]
nous nous sommes procuré les
enregistrements des négociations menées
par un ancien du gign
bernard meunier a supervisé les
pourparlers depuis la tour de contrôle
unique revendication des pirates leur
décollage de l'appareil en direction de
paris il est 8h30 le chef du commando
adresse un premier ultimatum aux
négociateurs
bien nous essayons une fois de plus de
gagner du temps de dire qu'il n'est pas
facile et bien d'avoir du carburant cet
or si
un jour de fête en france
que les mesures de sécurité ne seront
pas remplies c'est nous procédons à un
reflux ling avec des passagers à
l'intérieur enfin nous essayons de
mettre un maximum de barrières pour
repousser cet ultimatum configuration
nouvelle pour le négociateur de crise un
otage le commandant de bord sert
d'intermédiaire
dans l'avion
gros moment nous demande toujours ce
refus ling une entendus pour re décoller
pour dire que tout se passera bien si
redécolle alors ça a été
c'était ce fil conducteur ce fil rouge
durant les 14 heures passées sur le
report de marseille marignane il évoque
le fait qu'il est au courant de
certaines revendications
et quand nous posons la question sur ces
revendications il me dit il nous répète
que
quasiment qui les garde pour lui et que
il va là ils donneront leurs
revendications ils présentent leurs
revendications à paris mais pas ailleurs
il est confiant il dit d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises
qui les a regardé droit dans les yeux
qui sait que cd on déchante parole le
pilote appuie clairement les
revendications des preneurs d'otages
entente il simplement protéger la vie de
ses passagers où est il victime de ce
qu'on appelle le syndrome de stockholm
ce phénomène psychologique intervient
lorsque les otages vivent en autarcie
avec les preneurs d'otages ce qui est le
cas en ce détournement d'avion mais
lorsque surtout ils sont ne sont pas en
contact avec l'extérieur ce qui n'est
pas le cas du commandant de bord qui
d'ailleurs à cette situation un peu
paradoxale de rentrer en contact avec
les autorités
nous n'avions jamais été confronté à ce
type de situation syndrome de stockholm
passant aux stockholm donc c'est pour
cette raison que tu laves rappelé
syndrome marignane effectivement ce
phénomène peut se développer même dans
ces circonstances même lorsque les
otages sont en lien avec l'extérieur
sont en relation avec des gens de
l'extérieur
au fil des entretiens la menace se fait
plus précise
nous apprenons nous avons confirmation
qu'ils sont décidés à mourir donc si
nous sommes bien face à des kamikazes un
des pirates kamikazes et qu' il ya un
véritable arsenal inter de l'avion ce
que nous redoutions bien entendre
en fin de journée les négociations sont
dans l'impasse les risques deviennent
critiques à 17h15 l'assaut est donné par
le groupe d'intervention
les quatre terroristes sont abattues
neuf gendarmes sont blessés quant aux
otages ils sont sains et saufs
l'opération est un succès selon toute
vraisemblance l'objectif du commando
était d' écraser l'appareil sur la
capitale
dans le ciel de provence les hommes du
groupe d'intervention de la police
nationale de marseille depuis munich le
personnel spécialisé s'est
professionnalisé forte de 36 ans
d'expérience cette unité historique
dispose aujourd'hui de 24 membres
aguerris à toutes les techniques
dassault en milieu urbain
ce jour là le groupe simule un scénario
tristement banale de notre époque un
homme a craqué il est armé il s'est
retranché
la première mission des policiers lui
faire peur pour l'obliger à discuter
le forcené retranché en zone urbaine
c'est le cas de figure le plus
communément rencontrés par les
professionnels de l'intervention
variantes de cet exercice routinier un
des hommes du groupe est touché lors
d'un échange de coups de feu
l'exfiltration du blessé devient alors
une priorité absolue depuis sa création
d'unités n'a essuyé aucune perte humaine
dans toutes les interventions un risque
de médecins sont intégrés à la colonne
ici ce sont des urgentistes de l'hôpital
nord de la ville qui se prête au jeu de
l'opération on passe dans une deuxième
phase qu'on appelle la saucisse
thématiques qui n'est plus un assaut
d'urgence maintenant on va se protéger
avec nos moyens balistiques les plus
lourds de manière à engager la
négociation voir si on peut faire sortir
ce gala et résoudre la situation de
cette manière là où est ce qu'on va être
obligé d'aller au contact directement
mais là par contre on privilégie au
maximum les moyens de protection
balistique afin de progresser en toute
sécurité
un bouclier mise en oeuvre messieurs
oui
on va vous demander de laisser lancer
votre âme au milieu du couloir des
sorties en mettant les mains en l'air
le bâtiment des années monsieur on va
pas tirer on veut juste pouvoir les
mains et larmes et vous jeter l'armé par
terre et on sortait avec les mains en
l'air ou sur la fête
morales dernier retournez vous
mettez vous à genoux
à terre vous amuser et vous lui tendez
les bras
le surnom de l'homme qui est au sol
c'est le gros le vétéran du groupe comme
on dit dans le jargon de l'intervention
il a été saturé à la grenade offensive
et au fusil d'assaut il s'agit d'une
technique d'intimidation pour obliger
les forcenés les plus récalcitrants à
déposer les armes
pour finir menotté et de volonté
quand on participe comme ça
on
peut travailler mais sereinement
calmement mais aussi professionnellement
pardon il faut travailler
plus près du réel dehors un débriefing
de l'exercice est en cours il sera plus
amplement détaillé dès le retour au
commissariat
donc la mise en place j'ai rien à dire
la saturation voilà ça a marché parce
qu'il ya des commentaires particuliers
une exfiltration correct les toubibs
était bien là au rendez vous
a priori ça va les impressions du
impressions de notre plastron
est-ce que tu as eue est ce que tu as eu
envie de froisser le nez une fois que la
ville achète sa première cartouche oui
j'ai dit oui parce que à un moment donné
oui il aurait mieux fallu faire
accrocher un peu l'individu parce que à
un moment on était carrément marché ou
deux portes et quand même deux sous de
doser potentiel donc il voit retenue
faire venir nous n'y a pas des gens
comme le jeu il ya pas longtemps
16h il est temps de rentrer un terme est
décontractée c'est aussi l'heure d'un
peu se chambrer entre coéquipiers
et
j'appuie sur le bouton mois
les capacités de chacun sait va lui
aussi tous les jours pareil donc voilà
donc ça donne un peu ce genre d'exemple
là parce qu'il ya l'ancien est bon à
l'ancien il est quand même encore
malheureux et
et d'aucuns aimeraient pouvoir le cassé
en deux mais il tient encore
en route vers le commissariat avec nico
qui vient de prendre le commandement du
groupe avant il officiait à la brigade
antigang autre prestigieux service d'
enquête celui là pour revenir dans une
unité d'assaut lui a coûté deux ans de
remise à niveau physique les groupes
d'intervention de la police nationale
kadri l'ensemble du territoire les
interpellations délicates les prises
d'otages les forcenés retranché c'est
leur pain quotidien à l'égyptienne un
léger puisent dans leur globalité c'est
à dire les dix groupes que ce soit
métropole outre-mer ça représente 80% de
l'activité internet invention
c'est le fait
de notre
de nos connaissances de notre technicité
de notre existence depuis depuis plus de
35 ans
et c'est le c'est le gage de
travail
quotidien et aussi du temps
d'imposition d'un positionnement
géographique idéale puisque les groupes
sont sont présents dans quasiment tous
les plus gros centres urbains de france
métropolitaine et ensuite donc aux
antilles et à la réunion en
nouvelle-calédonie
donc voilà on en termes d'occupation du
territoire on peut pas faire mieux
[Musique]
au niveau d'activité et des succès sur
toi parce que manifestement
je croise les doigts mais ça travaille
plutôt bien même voire très bien à
l'arrivée rangement très méticuleux du
matériel la force de l'unité réside
aussi dans un équipement de pointe une
large panoplie d'armes conventionnelles
complétée par d'autres dites non létales
les hommes s'accordent ensuite un bref
moment de détente avant de reprendre un
entraînement d'athlètes de haut niveau
mené au sol est gardé au sol ces
policiers sont tous des spécialistes du
corps à corps issus de disciplines
diverses et variées on a des gens qui
viennent du penjab si l' on a des gens
qui viennent la boxe thaï un agent qui
viennent la boxe anglaise
gérad tout et tout est bon à partir du
moment où c'est sobre et réaliste on
enlève toutes les fioritures qu'on va
retrouver dans les disciplines
traditionnelles on cherche l'efficacité
retour au bercail pour le chinois et
retour aux sources pour le gipn de
marseille le commissaire divisionnaire a
donné ses lettres de noblesse à l'unité
il retrouve l'un de ces hommes qui est
aujourd'hui devenu le vétéran du groupe
c'est une de mes anciennes
vingt ans après sa retraite l'état
d'esprit du fondateur du gipn est
toujours présent entre ses murs
[Musique]
allez prenez
mettez-vous tout autour que l'on voit là
tous
les oui c'est génial et gardez vous
écris moi j'en pense c'est bien mais moi
j'ai eu mon tas en si bémol est
maintenant c'est passé mais rentrée ne
restez pas dehors
le prestige de cette unité tient
beaucoup de ce policier hors norme qui
s'est illustré dans des dizaines
d'affaires de braquage avec prise
d'otage le chinois a traversé tout un
pan de l'histoire judiciaire il a
affronté le grand banditisme français
dans son âge d'or autour du patriarche
le récit des hauts faits d'armes du
groupe a commencé et les preuves ont
commencé lorsque j'ai fait la prise
d'otage de de nice où je me suis offert
à l'otage et où je suis arrivé où il y
avait un bordel monstre à l'époque tout
le monde qui aller à droite à gauche qui
était armé non armés alors moi j'ai un
concept très simple que vous appliquez
vous aussi j'ai vidé tout le monde
dehors
mes gars dans une pièce
quand j'ai tous les renseignements
j'ai informé mes gars et puis j'ai mon
disque on l'appelle mon plan d'action
occupant 1 l'aca blement le devant de la
scène médiatique comme celui des
théâtres d'opération le patron est
toujours resté très proche de ses hommes
et puis je me souviens d'un gars que
vous connaissez sa grande gueule qui
veut lui presque les larmes aux yeux un
patron il paraît que maintenant que je
suis blessé vous allez vous débarrasser
de moi génial alors je vous garde
jusqu'à la retraite
il en pleurait de confusion et de voir
alors lui et parcours du m'emmerder avec
ses multiples femmes ses multiples
minots
mais c'est vrai vous avez la nostalgie
ce n'était pas
notre salut je me rends compte que
j'ai tracé un sillon
il fort heureusement le sillon continue
sa route
avec des moyens plus que valable et
les gars qui ont pris la suite
le héritte amplement
à ces jeunes héritiers le chinois a
transmis un témoin une certaine idée du
métier
giuly borotra au plaisir et
mais c'est aussi le symbole d'une époque
qui semble définitivement révolu au sein
de l'institution policière
[Musique]
aujourd'hui d'autres horizons s'ouvrent
aux forces spéciales françaises
sur le tee shirt de lionel un policier
confirmé du gipn l'éffigie des
blackwater
son site internet présente ce géant de
l'assistance militaire privée cette
entreprise supplée l'armée nationale
américaine sur tous les théâtres
d'opérations extérieures comme l'irak ou
l'afghanistan
c'est justement en afghanistan que les
mercenaires es ont rencontré les hommes
du gipn de marseille venus transmettre
leur savoir faire aux forces afghanes en
constitution
jamais nos sols je contrôle
c'est parce qu'on fait des jours de
formation paix ne ferons assure une
formation d'amiens histoire à kaboul on
a formé des groupes d'intérêts entina
repos là bas donc voila et on alors on a
eu la chance de loger avec eux pendant
les mois et de participer à certaines
opérations notamment donc il faut du
renseignement on va dire que il
substitue en quelque sorte un petit peu
l'armée pour certaines missions et
inter et renseignements les compétences
des techniciens français de
l'intervention intéresse beaucoup les
sociétés de sécurité privées comme
blackwater et c'est plutôt réciproque
tiens intéressant pourquoi c'était 100
pour le salaire parce que bon ce qu'on
appelle un l'aborder on va dire qu'on
est des salaires mirobolants et c'est
vrai que là on a tous de plus en plus au
problème
est lié les deux groupes voilà donc
qu'on a envie on a envie de partir en
voyage à nantes 2 de se payer une maison
est bon et ça nous pose pas de problème
donc c'est vrai qu'on est attiré par ce
type de mission non pas parce qu'on a
l'esprit aventurier parce qu'on a quand
même la tête sur les épaules mais tout
simplement parce que on a des besoins
comme tout le monde c'est pour ça qu
effectivement il n'a pas mal de de chez
nous en tout cas de pas mal de groupes
que ce soit militaire ou police qui se
dirigent vers ce type d'activité quoi au
bout de 15 ans dans la police selon leur
grade les hommes du gipn peuvent gagner
entre 1500 et 2000 euros par mois parler
de la rémunération de ces flics d'élite
s'est touché dans le mille d'un sujet
sensible j'ai réussi parce qu'ils sont
assez difficiles à venir jp mon carré
vient me voir avec un grand sourire et
ouais alors
le gipn était pète alors qu'on mène sur
la touche et en plus j'étais bien j'ai
des fusibles que j'allais toucher en
moins mais c'est vrai que ça fait un
petit port à l'est de voir que cobourne
dans le civil en touche notre salaire
fois six mort c'est sûr on est toujours
là donc ça veut dire qu'on a encore la
fois que notre bêtise oublier que ce
n'est pas si mal que ça de toute façon
et puis et puis c'est mon métier
[Musique]
en périphérie de paris un immeuble
anodin
c'est ici que se réalise un chiffre
d'affaires de 34 millions d'euros une
entreprise en pleine expansion
laurent combalbert est un négociateur de
la police en disponibilité depuis quatre
ans il travaille dans le privé pour geos
le leader français de ce qu'on appelle
la gestion de crise ce business est
développé avec la mondialisation de
l'économie dans des régions de plus en
plus instable
les entreprises implantées à l'étranger
s'expose à des menaces variés du
sabotage de leur outil de production
jusqu au kidnapping de leurs employés il
s'en produit près de vingt mille par an
la plupart past inaperçu et se règle à
l'amiable par l'intermédiaire de
négociateurs comme laurent combalbert
qui vient d'être récemment promu et je
continue à encadrer les équipes de
négociateurs et de gestion de crise mais
je dirais maintenant un terme plus de
management en termes de pilotage
opérationnel pure on travaille dans un
environnement dans lequel le soleil ne
se couche jamais puisque nous avons du
monde un peu partout dans sur la planète
on est tout le temps sur la brèche on
est tout le temps à tout le temps en
action ça bouge un petit peu partout
mais je dirais qu'on a une grosse
implantation en amérique latine
et puisqu'on a plusieurs bureaux donc
menez eu la colombie on vient d'ouvrir
un bureau au brésil on a également du
monde en argentine on a un bureau qui
est au mexique c'est une zone qui est
relativement active pour nous en termes
de en termes de business mais également
en termes de d'instabilité de gestion de
crise
l'afrique bien évidemment avec une
grosse filiale en algérie du monde au
nigeria beaucoup on a quelques
kidnapping d'ailleurs qu'ils sont passés
au nigeria l'angola également
une affaire parmi d'autres puiser dans
les dossiers classés de geos en amérique
latine des expatriés s'aventure dans une
zone reculée du pays et font une
mauvaise rencontre ce sont des coupeurs
de route ce à dire qu'ils ont arrêté un
4 4 qui passait qui par chance va s'est
trouvée remplis d'expatriés qui
d'ailleurs ont même été sorti aller
boire un verre dans une zone où on leur
avait déconseillé de le faire et en
l'occurrence ils ont fait kidnapper il
s'avère que dans les heures qui ont
suivi les personnes ont été libérées
sans paiement de la rançon mais que le
kidnapping s'est transformée à
l'extorsion il ya qu un groupe de
kidnappeurs a décidé de relâcher les
otages
sans demandé de rançon juste pour
montrer leur capacité à kidnapper
facilement voilà et donc ensuite ils ont
dit ben votre chantier va durer
plusieurs années on va vous sécurisez on
va vous assurez vous serez pas kidnappé
et un échange pour nous payer quelque
chose bientôt les choses se compliquent
comme le démontre cet enregistrement
d'une conversation téléphonique entre
arturo un négociateur local de geos est
l'un des malfaiteurs prénommé carlos
alo'o carlos comment tu veux c'est
arturo et comment tu vas arturo pas bien
a dit non tu appelles maintenant
j'appelle en avance c'était plus simple
de parler aujourd'hui samedi
écoute on a quelques problèmes mais ne
t'inquiète pas mon frère ça avance
le premier inconvénient c'est qu'il faut
réunir des personnes de l'entreprise qui
sont à paris actuellement
1 mais ils reviennent plus ou moins au
milieu de mois
adacore
bon et puis il y a un autre souci
d'ordre judiciaire
dans le secteur où vous êtes
vous savez que la bague ils ont
séquestré une française et un
vénézuélien
vous avez entendu parler de ça non
bon on est très préoccupé parce que dans
ces circonstances s'il y un déploiement
de forces de police ou d'un militaire il
ne faut pas penser que c'est de notre
faute
non non mais tu sais il ya déjà des
déploiements ici on a souvent même
d'abord les contacts se sont espacés
parce que la police a effectivement
déplacés dans la zone ce qu'il a un
petit peu refroidi on a réussi à faire
espaces et les contacts et les les
prises de contact donc pour nous gagner
du temps ce qui nous a permis d'envoyer
sur place des security manager qui ont
mis en place des dispositifs de sécurité
pour éviter que ça se reproduise le
kidnappeur ses lacets
comptant paurise et puis il a laissé
tomber son extension
du jour au lendemain on n'a plus aucun
contact avec lui alors ce qu'il a été
arrêté par la police est ce qu'il a été
abattu par une bande rivale ou est ce
qu'il a considéré qu'il est en train de
perdre son temps c'est un peu notre
objectif il a complètement arrêté dans
l'extorsion et notre client a pu
continuer son chantier dans de bonnes
conditions l'état-major de jos est
essentiellement composée d'anciens des
services secrets français parfois taxé
de repères de mercenaires les
entreprises de sécurité privées n'ont
pas bonne presse en france parmi les
personnels de l'entreprise figurent
également de nombreux retraités désarmer
comme le général heinrich qui a dirigé
le service action de la dgse
ce qui est intéressant pour les
entreprises ce qui est intéressant pour
tout le monde dans le cas de la
déconcentration
c'est d'avoir au sein des sociétés
privées des gens qui ont été bien formés
au plan technique qui sont des gens qui
ont de l'expérience et clients de la
déontologie parce que ceux qui sont
passés dans les services pendant
quelques années ceux qui sont passés
dans les armées peu ont une expérience
mais aussi déontologie donc c'est une
gare
[Musique]
londres tout un pan de l'histoire du
vieux continent et parmi ces traditions
méconnu la négociation privé c'est le
berceau de ce business comme
l'expliquent mme abbey lee un expert en
sécurité cet anglais a vécu de multiples
vies et par le sept langues dont le
français c'est n'est tout simplement par
de simples nécessité et les attaques de
piraterie maritime de prise d'otage au
brésil pérou en amérique centrale
philippines
plusieurs pays en afrique etc ça se
trouve un peu partout
ce sont des britanniques le plus souvent
d'ex-soldats le plus souvent de forces
spéciales qui ont
été appelés pour leur connaissance de
situations difficiles d'auto
préservation de capacité de s'entendre
de comprendre de
négocier avec des méchants des
des délinquants des guérillas d'autres
est très souvent aussi ces gens là sont
aussi ont peur eux aussi son temps dans
une difficile situation difficile et il
faut une personne d'une certaine force
morale pas seulement physiques pour
maintenir une négociation très tendue
dans une situation est spécialement
difficile
marc bélit a lui aussi négocier à titre
privé la libération d'expatriés en
mission de prospection dans un pays
d'afrique et commence six semaines de
négociations tous les jours leur demande
de jeunes leur exigence changent du jour
au jour
les interlocuteurs le change
remplacé par une
supérieure dessous supérieur bout
d'essai remplacé par de
deux subordonnés ils réclament quoi en
gros de l'argent
deux millions de dollars comme tout le
monde veut un million de dollars avec
bébé ils n'ont jamais vu de somme
pareille donc qu'ils ont lu ça donne un
jour me disait millions $
comme son nom l'indiqué le négociateur
doit négocier notamment la rançon et
plus exactement sa révision à la baisse
nous avons terminé aux alentours d'un
quart de million dollar pas facile à
mettre la main sur 250 mille dollars en
liquide et les banques généralement
n'ont pas beaucoup de liquide donc
mettre la main sur 258 dollars en
liquide a mis 3 jours
temps en europe pour une société
internationale
après de multiples rendez vous manqués
suscitant d'interminables expédition à
travers la brousse le négociateur a vu
le bout du tunnel à près de trois heures
de palabres à le faire c'est fait et
nous sommes rentrés avec nos bus qui se
portait très mal bien sûr après six
semaines dans la brousse à manger de
temps en temps une sardine mais
plusieurs poignées de riz par jour
outre le négociateur et l'entreprise
touché un autre acteur intervient
quelques fois c'est l'assureur les
contrats couvrons l'enlèvement
l'extorsion économiques ont été
inventées dans ce building il s'agit de
la lloyd's une puissante fédération de
compagnies d'assurance si mon cas ici on
est un courtier affiliés qui a accepté
de lever un coin du voile sur son
activité
ce concept d'assurance a été créée par
un ancien officier de l'armée
britannique qui est devenu un assureurs
de la lloyd's il ya plus de 25 ans à
cela a commencé plutôt doucement avant
qu'il ne convainquent un petit groupe de
courtiers qu'ils avaient un nouveau
produit qui pouvait trouver preneur
d'abord il ya eu toute cette époque des
brigades rouges italiennes pendant les
années de plomb
avant de glisser sur les kidnappings en
colombie qui perdure aujourd'hui
est maintenant bien sûr on gère tous les
problèmes liés au moyen-orient
ces contrats se situe à la frontière de
la légalité la plupart des pays
occidentaux interdisent la négociation
privé avec des groupes criminels
qui lie à certains gouvernements
principalement dans le monde occidental
qui considèrent l'assurance couvrant le
kidnapping contre rançon comme un
produit inflammable un produit qui en
fait augmenterait le nombre de rapts et
le montant des rançons
en fait c'est tout le contraire
le concept de l'assurance systématise la
négociation professionnels qui elle même
réduit les rançons s'il n'y avait pas
d'assurance il n'y aurait pas de
négociations fructueuses les rançons
serait donc plus importante est
automatiquement il y aurait davantage de
kidnapping
assureurs négociateurs sociétés visées
un jeu entre privés dont la plupart des
dossiers d'enlèvements crapuleux à
l'étranger les états et leurs
gouvernements font de la figuration
effectivement cela peut surprendre de
même que
la poursuite une investigation de délits
financiers et commerciaux sont
principalement dans le domaine privé
plutôt que les polices ou les tribunaux
de pays affectés ont seulement demande
pourquoi c'est très simple la justice
une justice nationale n'a quasiment pas
les moyens pour se projeter hors de ses
frontières de surcroît il est rarement
la volonté politique pour soutenir ce
genre de projection à travers les
frontières
depuis les quais de la tamise les
experts de l'international maritime
bureau scrute les mers du globe pour
recenser les actes de délinquance
maritime dans leur collimateur une zone
où la négociation privé tourne à plein
régime la somalie là bas les pirates
qu'il n'a pas tour de bras
il y avait cette année cinq cent trente
deux membres d'équipage qui ont été
prises en otage non maintenant si vous
prenez la situation aujourd'hui en ce
moment même où nous avons douze navires
aux mains des pirates somaliens
et 259 membres d'équipage retenus en
otage
et c'est sans précédent est complètement
inacceptable dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est complètement inacceptable que ce
type de crime puisse se produire à cette
échelle et n'irait h sans aucune
réaction contre ces malfaiteurs gainey
en cause l'état somalien trop faible
pour contrôler ses côtes comme
d'ailleurs le reste de son territoire
pour cela les côtes de somalie sont
contrôlées par des milices sans m'en
faut certaines d'entre elles soutiennent
activement la piraterie considéré comme
une source de revenus and sons vont
ainsi nous sommes en présence d'un état
complètement affaibli en tout les
pirates peuvent mener leurs opérations
en toute impunité ils partent au large
sont par deux navires croisant à des
centaines de milles des côtes
somaliennes ils reviennent avec les
bateaux
et ensuite commence la négociation
autour de grosse rançon à s'abstenir
france
paris quartier de l'assemblée une
entreprise française tente justement de
se positionner sur le marché somaliens
secopex a déjà entamé un partenariat
avec les autorités du pays ce jour là
les responsables se prépare pour une
audition devant un député membre de la
commission parlementaire de la défense
sujet du jour est d'actualité la
piraterie en somalie je pense qu'ils
vont nous demander de faire état de
notre capacité comment nous chez secopex
nous sommes en mesure d'organiser des de
mettre en place un dispositif dissuasif
qui serait de nature à éradiquer
voire du moins à
freiner les actes de piraterie ça fait
partie des jeux politiques la
communication nous sommes une société
privée et à ce titre dont nous devons
communiquer sur qui nous sommes qu est
ce qu on fait comment on fait le
lobbying entre le ministère de la
défense et les milieux parlementaires
est un passage obligé pour secopex seule
entreprise française aux anciens
complexe le label sociétés militaires
privées ont ce député pierre marziali en
championnat ce n'est plus des gens
frustrés
mais bon on a peur parce que ce matin je
vais là plus en retrait
viendrait surtout certainement vers 16h
17h ici là je pense que c'est ce qu'ils
ont prévu mais plutôt demain à partir de
demain
monsieur disposons combien de temps
durant 7
cette réunion après les civilités la
pluie le beau temps les responsables
sont dans leurs petits souliers il faut
convaincre le député de faire passer la
bonne parole secopex auprès de ses
collègues parlementaires comme vous
savez j'ai été saisi d'une mission
d'information par guy teissier président
de la commission de la défense les
pensionnaires au sein de l'assemblée
nationale ça cette mission fait suite à
l'histoire ou conan est le but de cette
mission c'est d'abord de dresser un état
des lieux et puis ce gouvernement
d'émettre des propositions et je pense
qu'effectivement vous avez quelque chose
à apporter dans le cas de d'abord de
l'information que ça venait à moi même à
porter et puis secondes et remonter des
propositions donc merci donc il m'a
répondu à cet appel je pense
qu'effectivement nous sommes en mesure
aujourd'hui de proposer des réponses
concrètes au problème de la piraterie
maritime notamment dans la région du
golfe d'aden au client au coeur de
l'audition la proposition force de
l'entreprise l'emploi de gardes armés
sur le pont des navires dans les eaux
somaliennes les débats resteront
confidentielles
à quelques pas de là chez les armateurs
français la cause des privés de secopex
est encore loin d'être gagné sa
représentante est franchement hostile
aux solutions musclé préconisée par
l'entreprise je crois qu'il faut éviter
de d'être dans cette zone le terreau de
peu deux mercenaires d'entreprises
privées de protection privées qui
proposent des services hors du cadre de
la légalité aujourd'hui ni le droit
français ni le droit international ne
permet de mettre des hommes armés à bord
qu'est-ce qui se passera si un jour il
ya une bavure qu'est-ce qui se passera
s'il ya des morts qu'est-ce qui se
passera si tout ça génère une surenchère
de la violence et si un jour un de
navigants et tué par un but marqué
contre son camp d'un d'un dédain de ces
mercenaires ça c'est pas possible il
faut qu'on évite ces solutions là et
pour cette raison là il faut que la
france maintienne une certaine dotation
hassan al-shammari mine à la marine
nationale si vous voulez ce qui trouble
un petit peu c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'état
étant un peu impécunieux a tendance à
transférer en termes de charge
financière au secteur privé en
particulier la sûreté il n'en reste pas
moins que la responsabilité légale
juridique est une responsabilité
régalienne et l'état reste quand même
très prudent dans le contrôle de ceux à
qui il délègue cette mission de sûreté
il reste très prudent parce que ça reste
sa responsabilité retour à l'assemblée
pour la fin de l'audition le rapporteur
de la commission semble entendre les
propositions de secopex tout en restant
très prudent
le seul blocage qu'ils puissent y aura
commencé le domaine juridique mais je
pense que cela se ce n'est pas tout à
fait dans le match dans la mentalité
française mais l'on peut exxon est
certes un levier peut-être pour faire
évoluer certaines choses et je crois
qu'il faut que dans ce genre de
situation est bien la loi puisse évoluer
on parle à faire évoluer d'un seul coup
ça me paraît absolument évident mais je
pense que petit à petit au coup par coup
on peut y aller d'autant puisque je
pense que dans le cadre de l'union
européenne nous ne soyons pas les seuls
regardez ce qui se passe au niveau des
chalutiers espagnols qui sont fait
pirater également de nombreuses fois
dans ce dense dans sept régions de
somalie je pense qu'ils sont exactement
dans le même cas
[Musique]
la privatisation de certains services de
la défense nationale qui sont encore
aujourd'hui le domaine réservé de l'état
c'est un sujet à l'ordre du jour chez
geos on pense même que c'est une
évolution inéluctable
corollaire direct de la réduction des
effectifs militaires enfin quand elle
est petit à petit en france comme dans
les pays anglo saxons s'est déjà
largement engagé vers une privatisation
d'un certain nombre de services c'est
inéluctable avec la diminution des
effectifs la diminution des moyens que
ceux d'hommes l'état pour remplir un
certain nombre de missions
[Musique]
passer du public au privé désormais ce
n'est plus un tabou au sein des troupes
d'élite qui chaque jour assurent la
sécurité des français
à toulon ce jour là nicolas sarkozy doit
intervenir devant le patronat français
afin de sécuriser l'événement lionel et
laurent de policiers du gipn de
marseille se sont déplacés pour assister
leurs collègues du gpn de nice les deux
marseillais seront postés sur le toit en
langage policier ont dit qu'ils assurent
des points hauts un petit cocktail et
ensuite ça redémarre d'ici ou de l'autre
côté du bâtiment en tout état de cause
cela reprend pas ce cheminement la sarre
passe par un autre point
ça va se déposer ici ça va tourner en
face à contourner le bâtiment et ça
repart après d'anciens
lionel et laurent sont tous deux des
tireurs de haute précision certifié
l'exercice et rigoureux il commence par
une étude détaillée de la topographie
des lieux
des gens m'en faire attention à tout ce
qu'ils voulaient fermer volets ouverts
tout ce qui peut roazhon obscures par
deux fois récemment des tireurs d'élite
du groupe se sont trouvés dans
l'obligation d'ouvrir le feu d'abord
face à un extrémiste lourdement armés
qui entendait livrer bataille contre
tout un commissariat à béziers dans son
véhicule lance roquettes
des kalachnikov des peines explosif avec
les des taux fait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour faire sa guerre au cnt comme il lui
dit c'est quoi donc c'était quelqu'un
qui
qui fréquentent régulièrement les
milieux islamistes et qui étaient en
rapport avec quelqu'un qui avait fait
les qui participent aux attentats du 11
septembre
puisqu'il ya eu des enquêtes qui ont
permis de remonter ça très clairement il
a été abattu cet homme
il y avait du feu
on n'a jamais quelqu'un par plaisir
malheureusement il a mis en danger la
vie de certains collègues puisqu'il a
pointé à me lance roquettes et il avait
déjà tué
une personne est
essayer de tuer beaucoup d'autres donc
je pense que
on lui a donné l'opportunité de se
rendre il l'a pas prise
plus tard c'est le tir de précision d'un
autre marseillais qui a sauvé la vie
d'un désespéré prête à se tirer une
balle dans la tête
il ya un mois un moment donné là il a
écarté tout petit peu larmes de sa tête
et le collègue a eu la possibilité de
tirer dans le maine pour le désormais
c'est ce qu'il a fait quoi ils étaient
80 mètres environ je pense que c'est un
beau tir parce qu'il fallait
moment avant le timing après quatre ou
cinq heures de derrière la carabine vers
la lune est il fallait
avoir les ressources psychologiques pour
le faire surtout ce tireur d'élite il
est où aujourd'hui cet ancien du gipn de
marseille qui était
une excellente recrue
qui s'appelle zizou à celle sur dents
actuellement il a quitté le groupe et
devrait pas être tard d'intégrer les
blacks auteurs pour des missions à
l'étranger notamment en organisant
lionel n'envisage pas de rester regroupe
jusqu'à l'âge limite fixé à 47 ans la
fuite des forces d'élites françaises
dans le privé est déjà une réalité
quelques minutes plus tard le convoi
présidentiel arrive devant un parterre
de grands patrons nicolas sarkozy
dissertent sur la crise devises sur la
dictature des marchés en toute sécurité
publique
[Musique]